عرض ستاند اب كوميدي للفنانه الامريكيه
كيفن هارت في القاهره يثير موجه من الغضب
في مصر فبمجرد ان اعلن عن العرض الذي من
المقرر ان يعقد في القاهره في 21 من
فبراير القادم انطلقت في مصر حملات على
مواقع التواصل اجتماعي تطالب بالغاء
ومقاطعه الحفل عبر وسم الغاء حفلت فيما لم
يصدر اي رد فعل رسمي من كبنهاورت حول
الحمله التي تنتقده المزيد من التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
غاز
بعد الاعلان عن تنظيم حفل ستاند اب كوميدي
للفنان الامريكي كيفن هارت لاول مره في
القاهره في فبراير المقبل صارت ضجه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[تصفيق]
لالغاء الحفله على خلفيه تصريحات السابقه
لهارت اتهمته بالعنصريه وتزوير التاريخ
مكانك في الهارت قد صرح من قبل بانه يجب
ان يتعلم الاولاد التاريخ الحقيقي
للافارقه السود عندما كانوا ملوكا في مصر
وليس فقط لحقبه العبوديه التي يتم ترسيخها
في التعليم الامريكي
[موسيقى]
وهو تصريح الذي اعتبروه تزويرا لتاريخ
المصري القديم
المنتشره في امريكا والتي تزعم ان الحضاره
المصريه اصولها افريقيه
[موسيقى]
علماء الاثار من جانبهم نفسه صحه هذه
المعلومات
[موسيقى]
الشركه المنظمه للحفل لم تعلق على هذه
الدعوات واكتفت بكلمه لا تعليق في ما يبدو
ان الحفل سيقام في موعده سمر بشات لصباح
العربيه من القاهره
سنناقش هذه النقطه مع ضيفتنا من القاهره
دكتوره هند الشربيني مدير عام البحث
العلمي بوزاره السياحه والاثار الدكتوره
هند يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه دكتوره هند تجلس الان امام
الاهرامات خلفها اهرامات مصر التي تدل على
تاريخ مصر فلم له من رساله اليوم دكتوره
هند اليوم سانقل لك نظريات المركزيه
الافريقيه التي تاتي على فكره بان
الحضارات الانسانيه الكبرى نشات من
الثقافه الافريقيه وان اصل الانسان من حيث
وجدت البشريه واستوطنت كانت في افريقيا
بالتالي ان مصر القديمه كانت ارضا للسود
للمصريين القدامى ما رايك
[موسيقى]
والله انا احب بس اصبح الشقه على حضرتك
استاذه المشاهدين هي طبعا حركه
المنظمه يعني عنصريه بغيضه نشات في امريكا
والغرب وبعد الدول الاوروبيه
بيدعمها
[موسيقى]
اللي هو من اصول افريقيه
طبعا هي ظهرت في مواجهه الغرب والحضاره
الغربيه البيضاء فلازم يرجعوا او يشوفوا
حاجه قويه تقدر تصمت قدام حضاره الغرب او
تبقى لها بذور ما لقوش الا الحضاره
المصريه القديمه
استندوا في كده لبعض التماثيل المصريه
القديمه اللي كانت بتلون باللون الاسود
وقالوا ان الفراعنه كانوا افارقه من السود
ودي نظريه طبعا مغلوطه لان هم لو قروا
التاريخ يعني يعرفوا ان اللون الاسود ده
له رمزيه عند المصري القديم وكان بيرمز
للاله اوزوريس اله العالم الاخر ما بيرموش
ابدا للون الشخصي مش معنى ده
بلون اسود ان هو دكتور هند دكتوره هند
يعني فقط لكي نفهم هذا الجدل الاكثر فاكثر
يعني هل تسميه المصريين القدامى بالفراعنه
ومساله الحضاره الفرعونيه هو الخطا الشائع
الذي يثير جدل لانه دائما هناك تركيز انه
لا تقول الفراعنه قولوا المصريين القدامى
هل هذا خلق ايضا جدل
ما هي الفراعنه هو كلمه فرعون بتطلق بتطلق
على الحاكم فهي يعني يعني همم ناس بقى
يقولوا ايه الفراعنه همم مصطلح على
المصريين القدماء بصفه عامه بس احنا
كمصريين احنا مصريين بنرجع وبننتسب الى
المصريين القدماء لكن رقم فرعون ده كان
بيطلق على الحاكم المصري مش كل المصريين
كانوا بيلقبوا بلقب فرعون
حضرتك حضرتك
طيب دكتوره ايضا كمان يقال بانه انه
ينحدرون من اصل افريقيا كان في ترجمه كلمه
مصر القديمه هي كانت يعني اسم مصر كما
دعاها تعني ارض السود
لا الارض السوداء
بالنسبه للطمي بتاع النيل مش قد الصوت لا
في فرق كبير جدا
امتدت للعمق الافريقي وجلبوا فعلا افرقا
كثير بس للعمل كحل الراس للمعابد والقصور
الملكيه وما ننساش برده ان اا دوله كوش
حكمت مصر في الاسره 25 فتره ضعف
الحضاره المصريه
ومنقدرش نقول برده ان هم كانوا افرقا لان
كوش دي كانت النوبه العليا اللي كانت تخضع
للامبراطوريه المصريه وكانوا متنصرين
وبيتكلموا اللهجه اللغه الهيروغليفيه
والملوك بتاعهم نفسه زي المصري وكانوا
بيحكموا حكام مصريين حتى في عصر
الامبراطوريه المصريه كان في عصر الدوله
الحديثه كان همم في حاكم انه بقى اخذ لقب
ابن الملك في كوش وده لقب خطير جدا فده
بيثبت ان النوبه العليا دي اللي هي دلوقت
حضرتك
عند الخرطوم كده
لغايه وقت حديث كانت السودان تبع مصر وكان
احنا بنعتبر ان احنا اخوه السوريين واحد
لكن كفارق افارقه جايين من من عمق افريقيا
او من الغرب همم حكموا مصر لا ده ما حصل
دكتور هند ما بتشعر انه فيش شويه نوع من
العنصريه مثلا يعني لما يكون في حاله
انكار شديده انه لا لا يعني مصر اللم ولم
تكون ارضا للسود
لا لا احنا ما بنقولش كده ازاي يعني بص
حضرتك لا احنا ما بنقولش كده بس هو دي
مغالطه تاريخيه لما هم يجوا ينسبوا
حضارتنا لهم لا ده ده غلط في التاريخ بقى
وبت- بت- بت- همم عاوز تنفي هوياتنا وتثبت
لنفسك هويه من لا شيء ما ينفعش ولا لازم
يعني لازم احنا نقف ونتصدى لدعوى زي كده
انا يعني ال- ال- كانت هتعمل مؤتمر برده
في فيبراير للماضي وتلغى كان في اسوان كان
اسمه العوده للجذور افريقيا الموحده
والعوده للجذور طب الجذور مين هو وعوده
لفين يعني كانوا عايزين يخرجوا في توصيات
ان هم يرجعوا تاني لمصر وان دي ارضهم
دي ما فيش الكلام ده احنا بنشكر شكرا